catherine hill bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
concernant al coronavirus les derniers
chiffres sont tombés plus de 3000 décès
en france donc 418 ces dernières 24
heures qu'est-ce qu'ils traduisent de
l'évolution de la pandémie
c'est assez simple le nombre de cas
double tous les quatre jours et le
nombre de morts double tous les trois
mois donc on peut avancer les chiffres
tous les jours mais c'est plus important
de regarder la dynamique globale
donc on est en plein dans l'épidémie le
confinement n'est pas suffisant les gens
sont pas assez confiné ceux qui
continuent à travailler risque d'être
exposés donc il faut réorganiser le
travail pour limiter le nombre de gens
que chaque travailleur rencontre par
exemple dans les ehpad il faut séparer
les gens qui sont positifs et les gens
qui sont pas malades et que ce soit pas
le même personnel qui s'occupe des uns
et des autres il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire du feu oui justement catherine
vous parliez des ehpad la prise en
compte des décès dans les épaves ne ne
semble pas faire partie des chiffres
annoncés ce soir puisqu'ils ont été
annoncées ces morts dans les hôpitaux
est ce que le compte ne serait pas plus
juste justement c'est en prenant en
compte un senior dans les ehpad de toute
façon les comptes ne sont pas justes
c'est pas vraiment le problème en
surveillant en regardant en ayant le
même outil de mesure
il ya trois jours et aujourd'hui et il
ya six jours il ya trois jours et s'est
elle même tous les jours ça va on voit
c'est la dynamique qui compte c'est le
fait que le nombre de morts avec l'outil
de mesure du moment
double tous les trois jours c'est ça ça
suffit concernés alors vous aviez estimé
le nombre de morts dus coronavirus en
france a au moins 64 milles vous vous
attendez toujours à ceux à ce chiffre
oui parce que en fait on connaît les
morts jusqu'à aujourd'hui on connaît les
cas qu'on a diagnostiqué et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui mais il ya énormément de car
la famille que nine et de raconter
l'histoire sont pas comptés dans les cas
donc il ya des quantités industrielles
de cas d'ailleurs du cool
la mortalité le risque de mourir être
d'assez faible finalement peut-être 1 1
et 8 % et donc il ya plein de cas qui
sont pas comptés dans le dénombrement
donc il ya énormément plus de gens aussi
qui sont contaminés est contagieux qui
se promène dans la nature et donc ça ça
va rendre la sortie du confinement très
très difficile il va falloir se mettre à
testé massivement la population à ce
qu'est oui alors effectivement on va y
revenir peut-être avant toujours à
propos de l'évolution de la courbe à
comps le pic selon vous ce fameux peak
tant attendue est ce qu'on peut avoir
une idée précise de de la radio dans
lesquelles il va arriver
la seule bonne est qu'on a c'est
l'observation ce qui s'est passé à
bombay à aubel on a qu'on a ou l'oral on
a confiné le jour où il ya eu sans
diagnostic
le même jour c'est à dire
extraordinairement tout dans l'épidémie
et on a confiné drastiquement bien plus
qu'ici parce qu'ici on parle d'envoyer
les gens les ouvriers du bâtiment se
remettre au travail et des choses qui
sont vraiment extraordinairement
déraisonnable donc un bourg ain avec un
confinement très strictes il a fallu
pratiquement quatre semaines pour voir
la courbe épidémique s'infléchir
donc ce que vous nous dites ce soir
c'est il faut plus de confinement pour
vous ah oui mais c'est pas ça pas moi
qui dis c'est n'importe qui qui a
réfléchi
tous les gens qui se promènent qui
travaillent qui rencontre d'autres gens
parmi ces gens là il y en a forcément
qui sont contaminés et donc ils
contaminent d'autres gens et ça va faire
continue alors on a réduit un peu avec
le confinement actuelle mais vraiment il
faut renforcer ce continent alors il ya
aussi la question de la chloroquine qui
qui suscite le débat la polémique en
france en europe et ailleurs quel est
votre regard vous sur cette molécule
ce médicament n'a pas été étudiée
sérieusement dans l'indication du
coville 19
on a des il ya une étude chinoise pas
trop mal fait
avec un groupe contrôle 15 patients avec
le
l'hydro xi chloroquine les 15 patients
témoin qui ne montre aucune différence
et à part ça on à l'étude le professeur
raoul qui sont extraordinairement de mal
faite avec des défauts d'analysé de
conception monstrueux
maintenant il dit qu'il a traité mille
personnes et que je ces gens là il y en
a beaucoup qui vont très bien je crois
qu'il a tendance à éliminer des gens qui
l'ont pas reçus traitement complètement
déjà ça c'est pas ça enlève tous ceux
qui sont morts vite ça rend les
résultats sympathique à regarder mais
extraordinairement biaisé ex trop
d'errements erronée dans tout ça n'est
pas sérieux
et en plus c'est un médicament qui est
cardio toxiques
les gens les plus malades ont des
problèmes cardiaques
souvent et donc c'est vraiment pas une
bonne idée du tout il faut attendre les
essais sont en cours ils vont aller
assez vite en la réponse bientôt
mais franchement c'est pas très
prometteur alors nyns nous n'y sommes
pas encore a néanmoins à quel moment
pourra t'on avoir la perspective d'un
déconfinement et comment faudra-t-il s'y
prendre ça je ne sais pas très bien il
va falloir être testé massivement avoir
une idée de déjà combien le virus est
présent dans la population et ça nous
n'en avons aucune idée aucune idée donc
on peut pas parler de confinement donc
on n'a pas résolu ce problème en tout là
bas
en tous les cas pour conclure les tests
de dépistage massif
elle est là pour vous la voie de sortie
aujourd'hui ah oui bien sûr mais mes
parts par ailleurs on n'a pas besoin
actuellement de tester des gens qui sont
malades et pas trop malades qui sont
chez eux comme la famille donc se faire
raconter l'histoire côte alors c'était
pas vital de faire un test c'est pas ça
l'urgence mais quand on va vouloir
sortir du confinement il va bien falloir
avoir mesurer la prévalence de
l'infection dans la population
merci beaucoup catherine hill d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes épidémiologistes et lanceuse
d' alerte